Hi, I'm Ryan Sumner and I'm with the IBM
Cloud team.
So, you're interested in VPC?
Well today I'm going to tell you how IBM
does VPC.
Virtual Private Cloud, or VPC,
allows the user of the cloud environment
to define Virtual Private Networks,
manipulate them, control them,
tear them down, recreate them,
and then deploy workloads into those definitions.
So, why does that really matter to you?
Why does it matter to the rest of the business?
Well, agility, security, isolation,
performance, scalability - I could go on and on.
But first I want to take you
through the building blocks that have
broken out into a few key areas to help
you understand truly what it is.
The first building block is all about the
core components that make up VPC.
VPC is an isolated logical network that you create,
but the first thing that defines it is where it's located.
In IBM Cloud we call this location a Multizone Region,
or an MZR.
A Multizone Region consists
of at least three zones that are
completely fault tolerant locations
within that region that have absolutely
no dependence on the other zone and
allow you to deploy your applications in
a resilient fashion. A VPC also defines
at a high level the IP addresses that
will be used for private communication
within that VPC, again across that
region. These IP addresses are further
used and broken down by allowing you to
create one or more subnets within each
zone. So, now you're starting to build an
IP network. You have complete control
over this, create one subnet for a flat
network, or introduce segmentation with
multiple subnets again in each zone. The
next building block provides a component
to allow you to secure your cloud
deployments. Security Groups are a
network function that allows you to
create rules that will either allow or
deny network communication in, out, and
around the VPC. Now, that we've created
our VPC and we've secured it, we need to
get connectivity to it.
IBM Cloud provides both public and
private access and different components
to provide connectivity for each of them.
For internet or public access, we provide
public gateway, that's your outbound
access. We also provide a floating IP
that you can tie to any of the cloud
resources that you've deployed in your VPC, providing both inbound and outbound
public access. For private connectivity,
we provide VPN as a Service, or
traditional direct link private circuits.
This is so you can extend your
enterprise into the IBM Cloud, or you can
even connect your VPC to another VPC,
or an outside resource. We're getting
close to deploying our workload in VPC
but first let's talk about what network
functions exist to help us with
acceleration and availability. IBM Cloud
provides a Load Balancing as a Service,
which is an application load balancer
capable of both HTTP, HTTPS with SSL offload
and traditional TCP load balancing.
Now, that we've built our VPC we've
secured it and we have connectivity in
and out of it, we can hand it over to our
application teams to deploy their
workloads. IBM Cloud VPC is enabled
today for virtual machines, deploy
customizable infrastructure, or
Kubernetes for those containerized
workloads. There are other capabilities
in VPC that provides security like
encrypt a block storage, or flexibility
like image import, and much more. I hope
all these building blocks help you
understand the value and benefits that
IBM Cloud VPC brings to you in your
public cloud journey. Thank you. If you
have any questions please drop us a line
below. If you want to see more videos
like this in the future please like and
subscribe and don't forget you can
always get started on the cloud at no
cost by signing up for a free IBM Cloud
account.